bueno pues nada homenaje es bastante
emotivos bastante sentidos uno de ellos
que se realizó aquí en este liceo ronda
la fontaine al oeste de la capital y yo
que ustedes ven a mis espaldas y
justamente durante estas conmemoraciones
pues estuvo presente eso míchel blanquer
quien es el ministro de educación de
francia él tuvo tiempo de hablar con los
alumnos de una clase de historia
geografía saber en que habían trabajado
en estos últimos días ellos e incluso
van a hacer un documental o web acerca
de la democracia de la libertad ahí tuvo
el tiempo para hablar con ellos para
reiterarles la importancia de defender
la laicidad que para él pues él
explicaba que es lo que nos permite a
todos vivir en una en una sociedad libre
en una sociedad donde estemos unidos a
pesar de que no se piensen y se crean
las mismas cosas luego de esto en el
auditorio de este colegio pues hubo este
minuto de silencio bastante emotivo y
también la coral del colegio que
interpretó una canción que escribió
vívelo para ti así que homenajes como
estos fueron los que se realizaron a lo
largo de toda esta jornada y el ministro
también explicó que lo que quería sobre
todo era que esto no fuera un homenaje
de un solo día sino que fuera algo
perenne y de hecho por eso hay varios
colegios y espacios públicos en todo el
país que a partir de hoy están siendo
bautizado sanmiguel para ti de hecho
mañana una plaza frente a la universidad
de la sorbona pues será inaugurada con
ese nombre